Hallo Guten Tag, mein Name ist Demir und ich bin der Disshabender für Sie heute zuständig.
Ja, kurz zum Ablauf, ich werde Ihnen zuerst ein paar Fragen frage, dann direkt Ihre Bechwerte übergehen.
Okay, wie heißen Sie? Ich heiße Michael Lindemann.
Michael? Michael Lindemann.
Könntest du Ihren Nachnamen ustabilieren?
Ja, Lindemann schreibt sich L-I-N-D-E-M-A-N-N. Lindemann.
Ja, okay. Herr Lindemann, wie heißen Sie?
66.
Wann sind Sie genervt geboren?
Am 25. Mai 1955.
Ja, 25.
Ja.
Herr Lindemann, was kann ich für Sie tun? Was führt Sie zu uns?
Ja, ich habe ganz starke Kopfschmerzen seit ungefähr, na, jetzt 10 Stunden.
Und die werden immer schlimmer?
Seit 10 Stunden.
Ungefähr seit 10 Stunden.
Im Laufe der Zeit sind Dich meistens schlimmer geworden?
Ja.
Können Sie Dich meistens näher beschreiben?
Ja, die sind mehr so im ganzen Kopf, aber ein bisschen mehr so im Hinterkopf und sie drücken,
so ganz stark drücken Sie auf den Kopf.
Dich meistens sind Dich meistens auf einem Nächsten Messer, von 1 bis 10, 1 lechter, 1 steht, leichte 10, 1 steht.
Oh, ich würde sagen, Anfangs waren Sie, zu Beginn waren Sie so bei 5, aber jetzt sind Sie inzwischen bei 8 bis 9.
Ich trage mich in einem anderen Kumpel, Jonas.
Nein, die sind nur im Kopf.
Ja.
Sind Sie onmachtig geworden?
Nein, aber mir ist etwas schwindelig und ich kann auch nicht so gut sehen.
Ich sehe nicht mehr so ganz scharf.
Haben Sie früher auch ähnliche Schmerzen gehabt?
Nein, solche Schmerzen habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Ist Ihnen übel?
Ja, etwas übel ist mir, aber ich habe bisher nicht erbrochen.
Übel ist mir, ich habe auch keinen Appetit.
Wann haben Sie das Liste mal etwas gegessen?
Ja, vor 2, 3 Stunden habe ich etwas probiert.
Ich habe einen Toast gegessen, aber ich habe keinen großen Hunger jetzt.
Das ist zu starker Kopfschmerz.
Haben Sie Unfall gehabt?
Nein, ich kann mich nicht erinnern.
Nein, ich habe in letzter Zeit keinen Unfall.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie sehr Probleme haben.
Ich kann in den letzten Stunden nicht so richtig scharf sehen.
Ich kann das nicht so gut lesen.
Das ist ein bisschen verschwommen.
Sehen Sie doppelt?
Nein, doppelt nicht.
Ich sehe nicht so scharf.
Okay.
Ich habe Sie an Ihrem extrem täten, an Ihrem Beinen und Armen eine Taubweißgefühl krippen.
Haben Sie etwas bemerkt?
Taubweißgefühl heißt sowieso Kribbeln oder Ameisen laufen oder so?
Ja.
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Nein, oder Misempfindung?
Nein, ich kann das alles bewegen, das geht.
Taubweißgefühl habe ich nicht.
Nein, das geht alles.
Können Sie gut durchschlafen?
In der letzten Nacht habe ich nicht gut geschlafen wegen der Kopfschmerzen.
Sonst kann ich gut schlafen.
Herr Lindemann, wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,82 m.
Wie viel wiegen Sie, derseits?
88 kg.
Hat sich Ihr Gehich in der letzten Zeit verändert?
Nein.
Nein, das ist zuletzt immer gleich geblieben.
Ja, okay.
Haben Sie noch andere Bechwerte?
Haben Sie Wusten oder Kreditschmerzen?
Nein, bis gestern eigentlich ganz gut gegangen.
Ich habe die Kopfschmerzen.
Ich konnte arbeiten und alles.
Heute sind Sie so Arbeit gegangen?
Nein, bei den Kopfschmerzen ging das nicht.
Damit kann ich auch nicht Auto fahren, das ist mir zu gefährlich.
Ja, Sie haben gut gemacht.
Herr Lindemann, fühlen Sie sich fibrig oder haben Sie Fiber?
Nein, ich glaube nicht, dass ich Fiber habe.
Ich habe auch in letzter Zeit keine Grippe gehabt oder keine Erkältung.
Können Sie sich gut konzentrieren auf etwas?
Normals schon, aber seit gestern mit den Kopfschmerzen nicht.
Jetzt geht das nicht gut.
Ich habe jetzt auch eben vorhin schon mal eine Schmerztablette genommen.
Sonst nehme ich nie Schmerztabletten.
Wann haben Sie es eingenehm?
Vor 3-4 Stunden, aber Sie hat überhaupt nicht geholfen.
Herr Lindemann, gibt es etwas, was für die Schmerzen Auslöser sein ist?
Auslöser?
Ja.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich bin ja nicht gestürzt.
Ich habe keinen Schlag auf den Kopf gekommen.
Ich kann mir das nicht erklären.
Meine Frau sagte vielleicht, dass es am Blutdruck liegt.
Ja, es kann sein.
Haben Sie leidens an krönchen Krankheiten, z.B. Blutdruckdruck?
Ich nehme Mittel ein gegen hohen Blutdruck.
Was nehmen Sie?
Ich habe ja ein Zettel mit.
Auf dem Zettel steht
Wiesoprolol 5.
Einmal morgens und einmal abends.
Seit dann haben Sie Blutdruckdruck?
Oh, 20 Jahre.
20 Jahre.
Okay.
Ich nehme noch Kandisatan.
8 Milligramm steht da.
Ich nehme noch eine.
Eine halbe Tablette abends.
Und dann nehme ich noch.
HCT 25.
Eins.
Eine morgens.
Und ich nehme noch eine Tablette.
Die ist glaube ich,
hat mir der Arzt gesagt, gegen Gicht.
Allo Purinol heißt die.
Allo Purinol 300.
Eine halbe am Morgen.
Hab es sich schon Gicht anfällt gehabt?
Ja, das ist schon einige Jahre her am großen Zee.
Links, das tat sehr weh, hatte ich auch starke Schmerzen.
Aber das Wort dann um mit Tabletten und besser.
Und seitdem ich diese Tablette nehme,
habe ich bisher auch keinen Gicht anfall gehabt.
Ich habe noch keinen Gicht.
Das war vor 5 Jahren, schätze ich, circa 5 Jahre.
Leider sind noch andere krönchen Krankheiten.
Zum Beispiel größte Krankheit.
Nein.
Ich gehe so einmal im Jahr zum Arzt.
Und lasse mich untersuchen.
Und messe auch manchmal meinen Blutdruck.
Gestern war er allerdings auch etwas erhöht.
Ich habe es heute aber nicht gemessen.
Sonst habe ich keine anderen Krankheiten.
Habt ihr Ihre Medikamente heute eingenommen?
Hab ich schon eingenommen, ja.
Gestern, was haben Sie gemacht?
Gestern, als Ihre Blutdruck hoch gemessen wurde.
190 zu 90 habe ich erst einmal gesagt,
habe ich mich hingelegt.
Aus einer Komponik.
Ich habe es heute nicht gemessen.
Ich habe erst einmal gesagt, habe ich mich hingelegt.
Auf Sofa und habe mich ausgeruht.
Und habe dann abends meine weiteren Blutdruck-Tabletten genommen.
Von diesem Kandisatan und von Bisopolol.
Ja, aber ich habe es seitdem nicht wieder kontrolliert.
Ich bin mal gespannt.
Vielleicht ist er jetzt auch ziemlich hoch.
Kann sein.
Wie fühlen Sie sich jetzt?
Wenn Sie möchten, können Sie sich auf der Liga legen?
Ich kann auch sitzen so.
Aber ich hoffe, dass diese Kopfschmerzen bald vorbei gehen.
Dass sie mir helfen können.
Brauchen Sie jetzt eine Schmessmittel?
Oder können Sie das Dichmessen am Ende des Geschenkeausfalt?
Ich kann auch etwas aushalten.
Wenn es nicht zu lange dauert.
Herr Lindermann, ich kenne mich.
Nehmen Sie noch andere Medikamente?
Nein.
Also die Medikamente, die ich Ihnen jetzt genannt habe, die nehme ich.
Okay.
Hab es sehr allergisch?
Reagieren Sie auf Bechtung der Medikamente allergisch?
Nein, allergien habe ich nicht.
Ich vertrage alles und ...
Okay.
Sind Sie durchgeimpft?
Geimpft?
Ja, gegen die Krankheit und gegen Corona.
Mein Arzt hat mir gesagt, ich habe jetzt alle notwendigen Impfungen
und ich habe auch die dritte Impfung wegen Corona bekommen vor 6, 7 Wochen.
Und ja.
Was sind Sie gekommen mit, Herr Lindermann?
Ich bin Tischler.
Tischler.
Was machen Sie auf der Bütte?
Können Sie für mich ein bisschen näher beschreiben?
Das habe ich nicht verstanden.
Können Sie für mich, Ihr Beruf, ein bisschen näher beschreiben?
Ja, ich baue hauptsächlich, baue ich in einer großen Firma, baue ich Fenster.
Auf Holz.
Okay.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie mit Ihrer Frau etwas Ihnen gesagt haben.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja.
Und leben mit Ihrer Frau?
Lebe mit meiner Frau zusammen.
Und haben Sie Kinder?
Wir haben zwei Kinder, die sind 32 und 33 Jahre alt.
Und die sind gesund.
Herr Lindermann.
Sind Sie raucher?
Ja, ich rauche schon ziemlich lange.
40 Jahre, gut 40, 45 Jahre und jeden Tag eine Schachtel.
Seit 40 Jahren.
Ja, gut, eher 45 Jahre.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, abends trinke ich eine Flasche Bier, aber auch nicht mehr.
Eine Flasche.
Herr Lindermann, nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich,
das ist eine Routinefläche.
Haben Sie bisher mit Drogenkontakt gehabt?
Drogen? Nein.
Treiben Sie legendmäßig Sport?
Nein, ich habe früher, früher habe ich Fußball gespielt,
aber das ist schon länger her.
Nein, richtig Sport treibe ich nicht.
Ich gehe mit meiner Frau viel spazieren
und wir machen Wanderung und fahren etwas mit dem Fahrrad.
Aber sonst regelmäßiger Sport sonst nicht.
Danke.
Ich habe noch ein paar Fragen.
Ich sehe es.
Gibt es jemanden in Ihrer Familie,
der an chronischen Krankheiten leidet?
Ja, meine Mutter, die ist 88 Jahre alt
und die hat Alterszucker.
Aber die ist ganz fit,
fühlt sich wohl.
Und der Vater ist mit 76 Jahren bestorben
und hat einen Schlaganfall.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, einen Bruder, der ist 69 Jahre alt
und der hat hohen Blutdruck.
Ich habe vorerst die Formation gesammelt.
Haben Sie Freude oder möchten Sie etwas ergänzen?
Ja, was glauben Sie, was das ist,
dieser starke Kopfschmerz?
Jetzt misse ich Ihr Bruder sofort.
Es kann auch, wie Sie gesagt,
hohe Blutdruck verursachen.
Dann werde ich ein paar körperliche und neurologische
Untersuchungen durchführen bei Ihnen.
Ich werde Ihnen Blutdruck nehmen.
Können wir noch mal schipteren?
Ja, gut, das ist gut.
Wie viel Zeit brauchen Sie? 5 Minuten?
Ja.
Okay, bis dann.
Hallo, Herr Oberarzt, haben Sie kurz gesagt,
ich habe einen neuen Patent aufgenommen.
Ich würde Ihnen ihn vorstellen.
Der Patent heißt Michael Lindemann,
der ist 66 Jahre alt, geboren am 25. Mai 1955.
Er ist 1,82 Meter alt und wegt seit 68 Kilo.
Herr Lindemann ist Tichler vom Beruf und verheiratet,
habe zwei Tochter und lebe mit seiner Familie.
Herr Lindemann stellte sich heute bei uns wegen seit 10 Stunden
und hat sich seit 10 Stunden auf die Bechtende geholfen.
Ich habe die Bechtende geholfen.
Der Patent ist jetzt bei 5 auf einer Schmerzskala.
hat der Patient sonst eine neurologische Symptome?
Nein, wurde vom Patient nicht verletzt, keine Lehmung, keine Traubarztgefühl, keine Parästhesie.
Und was sagt der Blutdruck?
Ja, der Patient leidet seit 20 Jahren Art. Repertension.
Und gestern Abend hat er gemessen der Blutdruck bei 190 mm.
Der Patient hat gestern seine Routine Medikamente eingenommen und sich ausgerucht.
Und seitdem hat der Patient Blutdruck nicht mehr gemessen.
Hat er eine Schmerzmedikation eingenommen?
Ja, vor 3 Stunden hat er eine Schmerzmedikation eingenommen, aber das hat nicht geholfen.
Wissen Sie das Schmerzmittel, was er genommen hat?
Ja, ich habe vergessen zu fragen.
Okay, okay. Wichtig, immer fragen, was für ein Schmerzmittel er genommen hat.
Gibt es sonst Risikofaktoren?
Ja, der Patient raucht seit 40 Jahren Zigaretten und eine Schachtelproduktur.
Gut, und der Patient hat einen Hypertonus und er hat eine antihypertensive Medikation.
Gut.
Ich habe ein Hydroklorothek, der 5 mg, 2 mg, 1 mg, 1 mg, 1 mb, 1 mb, 1 mb, 1 halbe Tablette am Abend.
Okay.
Und ein Hydrochlorothek, der 5 mg, 1 mg, 1 mb, 1 mb.
Hydrochlorothek, ja.
Und ansonsten leidet er hyperurikemy und vor 5 Jahren hat er ein Gechtanfall.
Eine Atritisurica.
Atritisurica.
Und dagegen nimmt er alle Prüner 300 mg, eine halbe Tablette am Morgen.
Okay.
Ja, gibt es eine positive Familienanamnese?
Ja, der Vater des Patenten wurde mit dem Alter von 78 Jahre ansila-Kanfall gestorben.
Er ist an einem Apoplex.
Apoplex.
Apoplex, verstorben, ja, mit 78, ja.
Und der Bruder ist 69 Jahre und leidet auch an altere Liparaturen.
Ja, okay.
Gebt die Mutter noch oder ist die Mutter auch schon gestorben?
Die Mutter lebt noch und 88 Jahre, sie leidet an Diabetes mellitus, Tipp 2.
Okay, gut.
Was ist Ihre Verdachtstiagnose?
Ja, aufgrund der Anamnissen am Gaugun, gehe ich von einer Verdacht auf,
vertransfer Krisen.
Hypertenive Krise, ja.
Perternseverkrise aus.
Und um meine verdachtstätigen Schlage, ich so erst eine körpellische
Untersuchung, besonders nörlische Untersuchung und die Blutdruck messen.
Und ein paar Blutabmähnen, natürlich durchführen.
Und um Apoplex auszuschließen oder um Hinblutung auszuschließen.
Gibt es in der Vorgeschichte, gibt es in der Vorgeschichte Hauffälligkeiten
mit wirklich eines Traumars oder einer Infektion?
Nein, es gibt durch eine unauffällige.
Ja, gut.
Ja, glaube ich schon, bei der Vordiagnose Hypertomie spricht vieles für eine
Hypertone oder hypertenive Krise.
Mein Vorschlag ist, wenn so ein Patient sich Ihnen vorstellt mit den
Beschwerden, sollten Sie als allererstes bei den Patienten nicht
sagen, sondern als allererstes den Blutdruck messen.
Sofort Blutdruck messen und zu schauen.
Wenn der Blutdruck jetzt dementsprechend hoch ist, wir sagen jetzt mal 220
zu 110, dann sollte man direkt den Patienten schon etwas Blutdrucksenken
des Geben zur leichten Blutdrucksenkung, nicht radikal, nicht zu schnell
runter. Man kann ihn Tropfen geben oder Biotensin oder je nachdem,
man kann ihm auch etwas Nitrospreis geben in den Mund, das kann auch den
Blutdruck senken, um zumindest erst mal zu schauen, wie ist der Blutdruck
bei den Patienten.
Wenn er sehr hoch ist, ist er ja sehr gefährdet, der Patient.
Er kommt ja mit starken Schmerzen, mit sogar Seestörungen,
mit einer Veränderung und deswegen als erstes Blutdruck messen.
Um das zu schauen, damit man da vielleicht schon handeln kann.
Und der Patient hat das sichere Gefühl der Empathie.
Es wird der Doktor kümmert sich um mich und stellt nicht nur Fragen,
weil ich habe so starke Kopfschmerzen.
Ich kann auch diese vielen Fragen gar nicht gut beantworten,
dass Sie da nur dran denken.
Ich würde es immer machen und ich glaube, das ist auch gut bei der Prüfung,
dass Sie sagen, als erstes messe ich mal Ihre Blutdruck, Herr Lindemann,
und kann schauen, wie hoch er ist.
Und wenn er jetzt vielleicht unter 200 ist, dann kann man erst mal sagen,
okay, man kann ihm ja schon etwas geben, aber eben das Ziel sollte
sein, den Blutdruck ja nur langsam zu senken und nicht zu schnell.
Das hat man vor einigen Jahren noch gemacht in Deutschland zumindest.
Das war manchmal zu radikal, langsam.
Und der Patient fühlt sich sehr von Ihnen aufgehoben und beachtet.
Das ist gut.
Und das ist auch gut bei der Prüfung, glaube ich, dass die Prüfer das honorieren.
Und dass man sich eben um den Patienten gut kümmert, Empathie zeigt.
Das denke ich, ist gut.
Aber so haben Sie das denke ich, gut gemacht.
Ich habe die Fragen sehr ruhig und klar gestellt bei den Medikamenten.
Da bleibe ich bei dem Schmerzmittel nachfragen.
Herr Lindemann, was für ein Schmerzmittel haben Sie genommen?
Ja, dass Sie das Präparat auch wissen, weil wir kennen ja ganz viele
Schmerzmittel, die auch Patienten nehmen.
Oder dann nehmen Sie nur eine halbe Tablette von Ibuprofen oder
eine halbe Aspirin.
Es ist wichtig, Informationen für Sie.
Was hat der Patient vorher schon genommen?
Aber Sie haben das gut abgefragt nach einer Trauma-Anamnese,
Infektionsanamnese.
Das sind, denke ich, wichtige Faktoren.
Woran denken Sie jetzt noch differenzial diagnostisch?
Neben dem Verdacht auf hypertensive Krise?
Ja, in Blutung.
In Blutung? Ja.
Okay.
Das hat im Augenblick, glaube ich, keine neurologischen Ausfälle
bis auf das Sehen in Visus, der etwas verschwommen ist.
Sie haben gefragt, ob er Torpeitsgefühl hat, Extremitäten,
ob er bewegen kann, möchte Extremitäten.
Man kann kurz den Kraftgrad prüfen.
Das ist eine Differenzialdiagnose.
Eine andere Differenzialdiagnose könnte noch sein.
Eventuell Glaukom.
Glaukom-Anfall.
Hirnblutung natürlich steht mit davor auch als wichtige Diagnose,
damit Sie auch notfallmäßig handeln können.
Das ist das, was ich mir jetzt mal gesehen habe.
Aber ich denke, das Wesentliche ist erwähnt worden und gesagt worden.
Ich glaube schon, dass das gut werden kann mit der Prüfung.
Dann haben Sie die Prüfung.
3. März.
Das ist ja nächste Woche.
Ja, und wo haben Sie die Prüfung?
In Münster.
Also aus meiner Sicht wünsche ich Ihnen da alles Gute und viel Erfolg.
Vielen Dank.
Ich werde Warnungen sind sehr gut.
Wir können nächste Woche noch einen Termin machen.
Dann bin ich im März erstmal etwas verreist.
Da kann ich noch nichts versprechen.
Das müssen wir sehen.
Das muss ich dann nächste Woche mit Ihnen besprechen.
Aber wir können erst mal nächsten Mittwoch wieder um 18 Uhr machen.
Vielen Dank.
Viel Erfolg für die Prüfung.
Alles klar.
Dann verabschiede ich mich und wünsche allen einen schönen Abend.
Schönen Abend.
Tschüss.